i'm piano stonestop i'm the
designer and original implementer of c
plus plus hey everyone james murphy here
this is a joint interview that i did
with tom from context free we're
interviewing bjarna strausstrup creator
of c plus plus i can tell that bjarna
deeply cares about the language and
about the people who use it so please
enjoy his perspective once you finish
this video don't forget to check out
tom's channel context free where you can
find the other half of the interview
even back in say like 2014 you're
already talking about things like
concepts and modules and ranges which
are only now being implemented in c plus
20 and in 23. so my question is
for today
what are those things that you're
thinking about for you know c plus plus
32
okay
uh 32 is probably a bit far in the
future for me
but uh
let me just point out one thing
i have to start talking to convince
people that certain things are important
even today um
there's lots of people that don't
quite see
the step that
concepts give to
the user templates and similarly today
i'm having a lot of trouble getting
people to understand the code machines
really are
not just cool and
such they are also important
and
one of the things that i hope for c plus
plus 23
is to get better
standard library support for core teams
to make it easier to use them currently
they're sort of an expert level uh
entity and that's not what they're meant
to do it's very easy to write with code
teams for the things where you really
need a stream of data generated or
pipelined
it's much easier to write coaching code
than it is to write it
with you managing the state and saving
it restoring it
again it's a simplification apart from
that it runs faster
but
people have to learn that and they're
not going to learn it till they get
the uh support from the library that
they deserve
okay then i end up talking about things
for many years before it happens
um and
i can tell about what i'm thinking about
now but this is
by definition half bit
please remember that of course of course
um so
i would
very much like to see uh static
reflection
that is reflection is
a dynamic reflection is basically your
code walks or a graph structure and does
something
and you you lose essentially all type
shaking you you lose the ability to
understand the code
because it's it's basically running a
little interpreter in the background and
if there's bugs in what you're doing
where there's bugs
in what you're doing it's not not
strongly typed
so i would like to get the effect of
that without the runtime aspect
moving
that kind of runtime stuff
through compile time
so basically i want to say
i have a program here generate for me
json reader and writer
for these three times
and um there's been work going on about
that it seems
have stopped a bit just now
we have to remember there's a pandemic
going on and
it's it's hard to meet it's hard to talk
uh the design of major features to
support new ways of thinking and new
ways of writing code
is you you need you need face to face in
my opinion
and i'm still dreaming of building these
distributed systems that's probably what
you're
when when you say 36 that's probably
where we're going with that
maybe i can build the system i was
trying to build back in
79
in a decade
yeah
let me just add one thing
modules is one of the major features of
c plot plus 20
and the standard library has not been
modularized
this must happen so that it becomes
easier to use
i mean i have run things that compiles
ten fifty times faster using modules and
again
you need some support in the build
systems and some standards for it to get
the benefits
from that
and the other thing that we are going to
see in the relatively near future maybe
not 23 but
maybe 26 is a general model of
concurrency which again will build up
towards
the the aim of dealing with more
distributed uh things
now of course c plus is a very
complicated language right now you can
do a lot of different paradigms which is
why i find the c plus plus core
guidelines very fascinating i find that
it
it simplifies and focuses a view of the
language i'm curious how the community
views that as a whole and also uh what's
the state of like automated um uh
verification of like compliance to c
plus plus core guidelines uh the core
guidelines came along
because i realized that you cannot
simplify the language
if you make a small
incompatible change
you can annoy a couple of hundred
thousand people
so
why don't we make a set of rules for
what we think modern c plus plus is
what about for people that are maybe
um more novice they're just getting into
c plus plus maybe they don't know c plus
plus at all but they're thinking of
learning how would you recommend for
those people looking to get into c plus
plus get started the way i think about
it is this true such
well at least two such groups there's a
large group of people who
have programmed for a while
sometimes in c sometimes in c plus plus
sometimes in other languages
that wants to know sort of the
fundamentals of c plus plus
you can't put them through a standard
textbook because it's boring and they
don't really need a chapter to be told
how to write a forum
this is my answer to that question
two of c plus plus i i realized that you
have to have something that you can read
over a weekend
and tell you what is in c plus plus
people come in and they don't know that
there's templates for instance
uh or they come in and they they say oh
you have concurrency support
or
there's a library for regular
expressions i've never heard of that
stuff
this is what this one is for over the
weekend on a transcontinental flight
that's
that that's the kind of book now
i also got a job
some years ago as a professor to teach
freshmen
and
that's a different group at the time
they either
half didn't know anything about
programming
and the other half
weren't particularly good at it even
though they thought that some of them
thought they were absolute geniuses
these are sort of natural freshmen right
these days more people have programmed
before but they have no clue why they're
doing it or what they're doing it they
just want to build a game or something
like that and
what's the quickest way of throwing
things together so i i had to write
i had to make a course and then i
decided i had to write a textbook
so i i've
run
many thousands of students through it
that's how i'm reasonably confident that
it works
and
other professors have not done the same
so i'm reasonably confident it's not
just me
and by the way i did not put my books on
the side because i was being interviewed
they're sitting the side of my desk
because i keep getting questions about
it where the answers are in the book
this is this thing here
um
with swanson and you don't do that over
a weekend this is meant for a student to
be able to do in about three months
taking a four
four course thing and there is a third
group that i care a lot about and i
think a lot about and i don't have a
good solution
and those are the expert in other things
that happens or want to use c plus plus
that is a biologist that wants to be a
biologist doesn't want to be a c plus
plus expert
sometimes they they use some scripting
language
or let's see python javascript and such
and they can get something to to run or
math lab
and then they notice that it's running
50 times
slower than it should and they would
like to get on board and do a little bit
of tuning to to get it to run somewhat
faster
and i don't have a really good answer
for how you help those
because the biologist thinks different
from the physicists and so on
but if somebody has an idea
they should
run with it
so you talked about
the committee what is the process like
of being on um a committee meeting what
do you guys do what do you talk about
how does it how does it work
the first thing to understand is that
the standards committee is enormous
it is unbelievably large
last meeting in prague when we voted out
c plus 20 those 250 people there
there are more people because not
everybody turns up so my guess is about
350 members
how on earth do you have a rational
process with that many people without a
management i mean the way you run a
company with 350 employees is that you
have rewards and your penalties
these are two things we don't have and
can't have in the standards committee
these are volunteers
these are enthusiasts they are there to
do good
and
not everybody's idea of good is the same
so we have meetings in between the
meetings
and there's a lot of email discussions
there's a lot of papers being written
these are the ones we discuss
and then it goes through a process
before we would and the way the process
works is we split up in many many groups
the two evolution groups are discussing
what should go into the language and
when they have decided and voted it
should go in
they pass it over to groups that
try to integrate the text with the
standard text
we have the standards committee meeting
where the technical people vote and
agree to something it is then given to
the iso that has the nation's vote on it
and as this happens the implementers
work so we get better feedback and
by that time the final vote comes the
first compilers start coming out
so uh
when it comes to these kinds of
interviews or ask me anything you do is
there any question you wish people would
ask you but they haven't asked
you know that's a standard question that
a lot of people
ask me
i usually for these very technical
interviews
try and drift a little bit into some
social issues
a lot of people
are in a desperate hurry
they want to get
their
current job or their current ideas done
immediately
and i'm saying wait a minute this is
life it's uh it's not a sprint it's a
it's a long distance run
make sure you don't burn out
make sure you uh do
other things then programming and system
building um sometimes
take care of the family
go see something
and
also
spend some time learning new stuff
foundational stuff instead of
getting more and more specialized
a lot of weaknesses i find the students
is in communication a lot of the best
programmers
are classical geeks
but it doesn't matter how smart you are
if you can't communicate your ideas to
others
then you could just as well do sudoku or
something
you have to get the ideas across somehow
and that involves communication
it means writing it means speaking
um
i mean there's people that are too busy
to write tutorials too busy to write
comments to
too busy to to do anything but getting
the code and then they expect us to pick
up the code and understand what it's for
and
why we should use it no you have to
explain you have to be careful you have
to help your users
i was just reading something
who said it but basically education is
about
what and why
and training is about how
i'm
mostly interested in education
though of course i can't avoid telling
people how sometimes
why did you choose say not to use
similarly directly when you started c
plus plus and so on
um i was a young researcher just just
arrived at billabson
i realized by looking at what people